okay hi everybody I'm so excited to be here
speaking at posit comp and I'm even more excited
that you all are sticking around for the very
last session of [Applause] posit so I work for
the state department of agriculture in the state
of Washington and we've collected almost 900
different soil samples from all across the state
and every single one of those Farmers or land
managers gets their very own custom soil Health
Report and this is going to help them understand
the soil Health in their fields and they can make
decisions on how to manage their fields based on
these reports based on this data how did we do
this we use parameterized reporting with CTO so
maybe you don't care about soils I've only met
one person at this conference who also works in
soils so I want to point out some other examples
of how you can use parameterized reporting so
there's examples of mapping Ocean Floors making
fiscal briefs or figuring out who the be which
state has the worst drivers so there's all sorts
of different ways that you can use parameterized
reports now why should you listen to me I have
zero Computer Science Background I have no coding
background but I absolutely love automating things
and I love making beautiful products so originally
when I started at the State Department of
Agriculture I was hired as just an environmental
technician I scooped water out of streams that
would get tested for pesticides So eventually
though I started to teach myself some basic R uh
R data wrangling and visualization and I applied
for a data scientist job in our soil section so I
went from water quality and field workor to soils
and data science and this is really cool because
I got to go from picking leeches off of my boots
to picking cats off of my keyboard so you're
probably wondering now how did I go from being
a non- coder to a data scientist and I had the the
answer is a skills test I had the opportunity to
learn something new parameterized report Ing
and demonstrate this ability at this through
this skills test where I had to create custom
soil Health reports for 86 different farmers
and I had one week to do this I had no idea what
a parameterized report was I was kind of freaking
out I was wondering how do I automate reports
and I sort of felt some existential dread and I
was wondering have I made made the wrong decisions
in life am I in over my head but lucky for me the
rstats community is so amazing I was able to go
down so many different rabbit holes and looking at
YouTube videos and blog posts and I went through
a bit of tutorial hell but that all got me to this
place where I was able to create these reports
with parameterized our markdown in one week
so these are the reports that essentially got me
my job and got me out of the streams and behind
a computer where I get to just chill with my cats
all day and work in case my boss is watching this
okay so fast forward to two years later we're
in 2023 and we've switched to quto because I
went to posit comp I went to our studio comp
2022 and learned about Corto and was just so
excited so in 2023 we now have HTML reports
where we're using leaflet we're using plotly
and now we have these cool interactive reports
but there's some people who would rather just
have a physical piece of paper so to make sure
that our reports are accessible to everybody we
created these Microsoft Word outputs which I then
manually converted to PDF because I didn't want
to learn lat Tech and Microsoft Word is so easy to
make uh template reports that have just out of the
box beautiful styling so this talk is the very
last session of the conference I'm tired you're
probably all tired our brains are full if you want
to take a nap please feel free because I have all
the slides available at the bitly link at the tiny
URL Link in this QR code but I'm going to have a
lot of code Snippets that I'm not going to have
time to walk through so I've included them and
you'll have to take a look later on in the um in
the slides okay so there's a generalized four-step
workflow um from the perspective of a self-taught
community taught our user where I first had to
learn what is parameterized reporting so we'll go
through a bit of parameterized reporting 101 and
then we're going to talk about subsettable data
and how to get our data ready for parameterized
reports and then we'll talk about making sure that
our content is interpretable and understandable
to our readers and also accessible so our font
sizes color contrast and for the python users
in the room the parameterized Corto reports
can also be used with the Jupiter engine as
well as the nitter engine so take a look
at your the the quto docs for the syntax
differences okay so Step One is learning
about parameterized reports so what is it it's
essentially a template report where it's going
to have placeholders where you can then fill in
um whatever values you need so what really helped
me to think of parameter reports as functions like
really comp Lex functions so imagine you have a
quto file and you're trying to report something
um for every single year so this function or
this template is going to take in parameters
as the function input essentially so if you are
producing all these reports for each year instead
of going through and changing 2019 to 2020 to 2021
you're going to put in pams dollar sign year and
then that the output of your function are going
to be these reports for every single year without
copying and pasting it's amazing okay so for your
parameterized report you'll have a yo header which
stands for yet another markdown language and
this yo header is going to contain your basic
metadata so your title subtitle date author that
fun information it'll also be where you specify
your format types so in our case output to HTML
and where Doc and this is also where you're going
to set your parameters so these are key value
pairs where you're naming your parameters and
then you're also naming uh the default value
that it will use below your emo header is going
to be your basic report content now how do you
access your parameters when if you're working
in R Studio interactively you can run any line or
code chunk and this is going to add this paramed
object to your environment and then because this
is just a list object you can use the standard
list notation and access these parameters with
pams dollar sign farmer and then that would give
you like Sammy sunflower and you can also use
parameters for inline code so if you enclose your
expression and backtick R your expression backtick
it will dynamically calculate or render whatever
your parameter is so for example we have these
are results for prams dollar sign farmer Sammy
sunflower now how do you render the reports so
the fastest way to just iterate over your reports
and edit and get the look and the feel right is
using the IDE and using the render button and if
you hit the little arrow you can choose between
all the different outputs um that you've specif
speci ified in your yaml um if you like hot keys
or short keyboard shortcuts like I do you can
use control shift K and that's super helpful and
another Nifty feature is the render on Save option
where if you have that checked every time you
save your file it's going to render that report
and then you'll be able to see your HTML preview
update if you're rendering to HTML and it should
be noted that the this way of rendering these
reports are going to use your default parameters
uh that you've specified in your yo and it's
also going to have the same name and the output
file location as the input file now you can also
programmatically render your quto files using the
quto render function and this you would include
it you would run this in your console or in a
separate iterate R script or whatever you want to
call it and and you're going to specify your input
file your output format type the output file name
and then your named list of parameters and this is
especially helpful for when you want to render all
of your reports at one time so to do this we're
going to create a data frame that has two columns
and these column names will match our CTO render
arguments the first is output unor file and this
will contain the file name with the extension and
then execute undor prms will have the named list
of parameters and so here's the an example of code
I'm not going to talk about but you can check out
later to get this basic two column data frame that
has the output files and the ex the parameters
and we can use the per pwalk function to iterate
over each row of this report data frame and we'll
just again specify the input file name and the
output format which is going to match the um file
extension that you had in this reports data frame
and this is where the magic happens I've heard
the the term magic being said so many times at
this conference it's simply amazing but seriously
it's pure magic so this is all the files being
knit back to back from one function called and you
can see all the documents are just being populated
in the files paint it is absolutely amazing and
I figured that out at about 2 in the morning um I
don't know why that was not hidden but uh yeah I I
figured that out at 2 in the morning the day I was
supposed to turn in my skills test and I ran into
the bedroom and I woke up my husband and I was
just so shocked and excited I yeah probably looks
like Pikachu and my catm okay so now we're going
to talk about getting this data ready for our
parameterized reports so we're preparing data that
is subsettable and this is just a simplified data
frame where we have our year and our farmer and
these are again our parameters and some example
data and yes thanks chat GPT for the puny farmer
names um so you can use these params as basic
values so here we're just using decler filter
and then setting our farmer equal to whatever that
Pam's value is so we're doing some data wrangling
here and creating a new column called category and
for each farmer that is being the report is being
rendered for that value would be your fields for
any samples that are in the same crop it would be
same crop and then any other project uh any other
samples in the project would just be called other
fields and this is going to come in handy when
we do our visualizations for our reports so now
we're going to create our content so we want to
make sure that it's easily consumed by whoever we
are sending these reports to that they're able
to understand and make decisions based off of
what you're showing them so one way we did this
was creating these static plots and interactive
plots for HTML format but we're now using that
new category column and we're styling each point
so that it's really clear that the uh for to the
farmer which are their fields which points are the
uh fields that are in the same crop or the same
county and then just the General Distribution of
the project and this helps um people to interpret
their data based on comparing it with other uh
other points so we also want to make sure that our
reports are self-contained so we want to make sure
that we are providing all the content for our
readers to really understand the results that
we're showing them so we want to uh so we included
about 30 different soil Health measurements and
instead of including 300 lines of just regular
text and pros of what these measurements were we
can use a include short code that's actually
going to just embed this other quto document
that's called soil Health measurements into the
parameterized parent quto file and it makes it so
easy to reuse information across your different
reports and it shortens your your main document
and I also mean self-contained in the more literal
sense for the HTML reports where uh we want to
make sure that we can just send the HTML file
email it whatever and then the recipient can just
open it off the bat and so to do this we'll do an
include in yaml or we we'll do um embed resources
true in the yaml header and what this is going to
do is make sure that all the data images Styles
sheets Etc are embedded into that file because
otherwise quto is going to give you a underscore
files folder that has all of those external
dependencies and if you send that with your
HTML file no one's going to know what to do with
it so make sure you embed and then also make sure
you're mindful of size so if you are doing these
self-contained reports don't make them too big
that you can't email them so just just a heads up
on there okay and then designing for accessibility
so I already talked about about how we created
HTML reports and PDF reports so Corto makes this
really easy by using these divs where we can use
this content visible when format is HTML and this
is really helpful when we want to use panel tab
sets for just our HTML reports so that we don't
have to have a whole long list on our HTML file
we can have tab sets for each category of our
soil measurements and for non-html files we can
use the content visible unless format HTML div
and now we just have our background information
and a regular list of definitions we also can use
conditional code evaluation where the code will
only be evaluated if the output format is met so
for example if we wanted plotly code only for HTML
or ggplot code for anything else to do this we're
going to set an output format type in our setup
chunk using this snitter Ops snit get function
and then we can use this outtype variable uh value
in our eval chunk option and now we're including
both of these code chunks in our document but only
the code chunk that is has that eval um evaluated
to True um will actually render and be included in
your report so here's some tools for by uh styling
and picking your colors and contrast um and you
would include this in your yaml header for HTML
output Word document and these are listed in the
resources and I don't have time to talk about the
um browser developer tools but this is here for
you um to double check your contrast ratios for
your HTML reports and what's really Nifty is
if you click on it you can actually adjust the
color but again I don't have time so um the end
result though was um everybody gets their very own
custom decision support tool so that's essentially
what parameterized supports can be if you design
them right and um provide all the context that's
needed to understand those results so um to recap
we learned a little bit of parameterized reporting
101 uh we saw that we can just use our data that
has columns for each parameter and then we made
sure that our content is easily understandable
and is accessible to all of our audience and now
because we didn't copy and paste we didn't do each
of these reports manually we now have time to take
a cat nap watch TV hang out or work if my boss is
watching this okay so I promised you seven slides
of resources so I have all the resources that
well not all a curated list of resources from my
immense times of going through all these different
rabbit holes so there's um the quto docs and
videos uh tutorials examples videos style sheets
accessibility tools and I would love to connect
with you over My Favorite Things cats feature are
and Corto and I'm sure we're all feeling like
this and ready to go home thank [Applause] you